okay so after the previous great talk
where we learned how easy and fun it is
pandas this time we'll listen from our
Garcia who is the maintainer of pandas
what is broken with it and how we break
it even more thank you can you hear me
okay yeah things things a lot for for
attending my talk just a disclaimer I'm
losing my voice I makeup is not perfect
and my tone may be a bit a bit low if I
don't sound very excited it's not
because I'm not excited about being here
I'm very excited just
I'll keep I'll try to keep my tone
enough to to have voice until the end of
the talk so alistair yeah talking about
breaking pandas and to break pan - what
better than a live demo and it would be
an easy one because panda is expected to
break so if it breaks this is good
that's usually the main worry about
about demos so let me start see if I can
make it big enough okay mister by
importing pandas there is a new feature
of pandas that you can import pandas
without being a speedy and it works in
the latest version okay this is this is
master don't try it in in your version
might not work then I'll open some some
data well daddy I didn't show it long
enough but I've got I'll get some data
about the resilience of the United
States and I'll try to answer answer
these questions who was the younger like
- today they who talk of his being the
oldest person and who was the president
for a for a shorter shortest period
pun discusses really any cool filters
including that you can provide anything
that it's kind of reasonable in in the
file you want to open even if it's in a
in a website that needs to be downloaded
and even if it's if it's compress pandas
in general takes care of of everything
okay trying to make things of it with
complex for pandas but it works well and
to try to answer the first question okay
who died tada at a younger age the
youngest age what I will do is just like
to take the death here
and get it interesting here that was the
question or I did it at the younger age
okay let's answer some more questions
like who took office Adams who took
office being the oldest one actually I
didn't going a bit first but I'll do
something
I said president it was I actually quit
focused on
and yeah the first question the answer
is Canada I wonder I wonder that why is
that let's go for the second question
whoo-hoo - coffee is who took office
sorry took office being the oldest for
that I'll just get like from the two
coffees
I'll get the year and then I will
subtract the birth the birth year can I
have an arrow panda is not really broken
here
he just like JSON doesn't support like a
date-time format so everything that we
got from the JSON that look like a date
was actually a string so let's just
start melting things if you know
anything about pandas you might know
about the the types we can see also an
interesting thing here you realize
you've got these in many cases if your
regular pandas user that it's like the
year here the Deaf here is converted to
a float that's because there is some
president that are still alive so there
are missing values in these in this
field so pandas has something nice well
you saw that the type is is float pan
discuss something that is like now that
they death yeah well if I try to convert
it back to arms back to
that is failing it will tell me that
there are missing values or infinite
values or they don't have a
representation in it's not a pundit
limitation issues like a hardware
limitation there is no representation
for integer values but in the newer
versions of pandas we've got something
that that we actually have a type
integer type that why is that oh that's
not how I expected it to break okay I
have yeah okay I repeated here yeah
that's actually
so yeah yeah yeah sorry sorry about that
yeah let me just add a tag and then it
should be easier its reassigned the
index so yeah and now we write here
notice this actually got converted to an
integer if I got the types is a is a
different you see the capital in the
capital I or the lowercase I for the
original type the capital for the for
the one that support missing values and
then we the original problem actually
was going a bit is low but I'll try to
speed up a bit like the two coffees that
needs to be a great time that that was
actually order over or is not problem
I'm the same
for the left office
okay there's only looking looking better
this look will look the same we can not
tell if it's if it's just doing or not
and this one that was broken now it's
returning me there the year and now I
can check like who was there who was
there the oldest one
it was mr. Trump so now we can do
something else well I'll just do I
shouldn't do that much time but I think
it's reasonable if I have if I want to
clap the my my types reasonable party is
just like a limited set of values I
don't think it's that much required to
save different strings I can just like
kind of encode the mass as categories
and it this is a much much better
representative that's a much better
representation so now I don't have
objects anymore that objects are slow in
there are Python objects and there is
low in in pandas so now what I wanted to
know is who who was less last time a
president there is something quite nice
in in pandas we can create like an in
office a column that it would be an
interval between two two periods for
that the syntax is a bit trickier I'll
discuss about this have it later
you know looks like and then I will say
that I won since the president of the
office until the president left the
office and this is breaking in this case
it's for an oh well in this case is
because I did something yes things it
would like like this team working that
tell me what's wrong you can come to my
office if you wanna I need it all the
time yeah but it's telling me where
there is a limitation the way that
intervals are represented they are they
can have missing values but just a
missing value not like a part of the
interval missing so or you have like the
the whole thing it's it's missing and or
it is not in this case we have a problem
here that is that one of the presidents
actually didn't live off ops didn't
leave leave office so there is a there
is a missing value okay that's actually
a problem that we're gonna fix and
actually there are many ways I think I
can let you choose which one we can make
him leave office today we can also we
can also change the value so he never
took office or we can delete him totally
that's very easy to do in in bundles we
can do but we can we can probably yeah I
yeah let's say that
and yes lock the president in question
is dono J Trump and I'm gonna say that
that office today
that's great cause I hope you're happy
because our interval array will work not
for any other reason
if you were if you would prefer actually
we could even go to the past and say
like okay you actually never took office
let's say in any case we can create over
interval yeah created or interval and
now we have this column that it's an
interval and from it we can just get
like the enough is say a rate the length
that will return as the the length and
actually now if I want to use this I
need to convert it to a serious that's
of this but this actually it's not a
great syntax that's kind of like the
point of this talk now we have like the
exact dates that they were in office and
we wanted to know they're the shorter so
long so we've got yep
so this is the guy who took office less
and I did actually a mistake at the
beginning when I was showing the who was
the the maximum who took office now is
actually they're not written because we
we remove him like from office but the
point there are a couple of things
actually one of them didn't fail some of
the problems that I am showing here
because I did something in the order
that I was not expected to do but the
first thing is that we converted things
to data time very easily we spun this to
date time we converted things to
interval with our extremely difficult
syntax I would say like that something
kind of variable easy to solve but
I think it's a something that it will
come later we also got that this column
dot length what will could have just
like calling the length actually we had
to create these like the the whole thing
here and actually we have to create this
we have to call these disarray that it's
the underlying representation of Panda
is something kind of internal just to
get the wee one
and we didn't make this fail because I
didn't catch the time before getting the
first president but actually they after
converting to the integer with missing
values you cannot compute the idea extra
marks so why is that Pandit relies on
numpy all the internal representations
are number based for the internal terms
of numpy was like the origin of pandas
and the support is extremely good but
pandas implements many other things and
and they are growing that are like what
we call external extension a trace okay
that it's like date times that are aware
of the time zone it's something that
numpy doesn't support also ten deltas
also period the intervals is the one
that we saw then no liable integer is
the one that we also saw we also have
the categorical the sparse so twist as
as you saw there are several things that
that imp understand work quite the same
or they are not as as mature when you
are using non PI types and when you are
using like extension arrays that was
supposed to be a live demo but actually
I'm already quite late on time so I'm
going to and just run it like this okay
it just still that's kind of important
because they they bundle 24 to the
latest version has a small changes in
the syntax nothing important that it's
relevant but so you know that if you try
to run these examples it needs to be on
master okay we can define our custom
types don't worry as much about the
exact syntax but we just tell a name and
we say like that the type of an element
in our in our series you know where
erase it will be an object in this case
a Python object what I'm doing is just
like representing instead of numpy
representing things storing things
internal in pandas in a in a Python list
then I create this class of array that
it represents things like how are you
going to get the data and how are you
interest or like computing the length
converting it to num by adding two
values like which the type is associated
to
nothing really fancy and quite short and
with this we can do things like rating
aware over on Sirius okay with our
series with our own types okay that's
actually kind of straightforward if you
don't called many operations in this
case I implemented that so I can just
like at one here easily
I didn't implement the subtract so if I
try to subtract something I it will fail
but I've got my my custom type it's a
kind of a very small version but and
then in many cases if I'm implanting my
custom format actually what I want to do
also is do a specific operations like I
saw it in interval what we thought we
don't provide this for interim interval
yet but it should be easy to implement
if anyone really cares about this data
type that is like the accessor so I have
my serious and on my serious I can I can
define these pyl or whatever I want that
is what a resistor here I clear that a
class that has a property in this case
and then I'm able for a serious to
access this property that I define that
I define here this so in this case I'm
just reversing simple function that goes
today to the Python object and it
returns the the type so this is how cool
things are represented in Python they
said like numpy has a different it's
like as simpler somehow a more like
close to the core everything that it's a
custom type actually in pandas is
implemented it in this way and as you
see there are different levels of of
maturity and and it's not it's kind of
recent this was introduced in recent
versions I still work on progress but
you see that it's actually making things
much easier in in our site so after
after this I said like the idea here
about breaking pandas is that pandas is
huge like the API of pandas is huge and
what we have is that is that it's
growing even more and an overcoat is
being affected by that it's getting
batteries that were implementing like
these extension so not everything needs
to be in pandas you can implement things
separately like the eraser erase and the
types that I shown like for example
internally it's included the excess
sourced works is this and there are some
examples
ready of this like geo pandas is using
that cyber panda sieve you want to
represent IP addresses you all can
represent with a specific format and
having a specific operations Fletcher is
an ro anaerobic and for representing for
example strings in a very efficient way
that pandas is not because it's using
Python Python strings so I think my
point of the talk a bit is just like to
explain that we need to keep breaking
pandas I'm making it pandas more
extensible and actually like making even
the internal things that pandas provide
like making it like in a in an API one
of the first thing that it's already
almost implemented should be ready for
the next version is plotting back-end so
this course they mean in a second each
of them another one that it's under
discussion and we'll see what it happens
is there are your plugins and then like
having direct methods the same as the
accessors as I so like this is a an
accessor this thing over here but just
being able to have like direct methods
like if my data is interval why not like
being able to call lengths directly and
so plotting back ends they're already
several plotting backends they are using
different api's and they are doing
monkey patching and we are things that I
think they don't they shouldn't be using
I think we should be better in pandas to
let them interact with us so for example
if you want to plot in pandas you would
plot like this in all of yours if you
use this extension you're this plug-in
or module you you would use this
function so it's totally independent of
pandas pandas don't play nicely on
letting you plot in whatever you want
what we are adding now is just like
having a pandas option that you can
specify the the plotting button and in
the in the backend actually you should
will have the same API for every back
end you will be able to plot in Bocca
you'll be able to plot in in altair or
whatever it is and third-party
developers would be able to provide like
modules that you can plot in in anything
if you want to plot in ask you why not
just do it so we'll have one API to roll
them all I think that I would think I
mean the standard a packages would also
be more consistent among them it would
be easier for for developers to get
started we'll have better documentation
for the API everything would be more
uniform adding not just really good
thing in terms of
are your plugins ok Pandit is supporting
all these all these input and output
things is able to read from CSV I'm sure
you know read JSON use your site in the
example is able to read on from HTML
from the clipboard from Extell per K is
quite a great format to yours like well
so hot like pickles I'm wearing here and
also some like like commercial software
status and Google bigquery and that so
lots of things in here and also this if
you are an have any that it's missing
this is other formats this is not
property or is like not they might
saving to this for accessing a yoga this
is like different representations like
in in-memory representation like Python
Diggs latex or strings or or whatever
but there are some that many that are
missing like for example it's able to
export in import in Extell but it's not
like the format they and they open sort
of open standards format like all the s4
libreoffice XML I assume Java people
would be happy if we are able to export
things in XML like data frames and maybe
generate an image maybe a PDF it was
someone who develop a library and was
asking us if we wanted to include it
markdown we got an issue for that and
I'm quite sure lean with time you will
you will get more formatting here so
what I personally think it's a bit wrong
is that the moment we're making a
decision we're taking like the
responsibility of saying what is in
pandas and what is not and what it's not
in pandas it not support it and it's
kind of like Nikki library that we don't
care about what I think we should
probably do is like make every one of
these are your modules may can make them
like plug-in even if we distribute them
with pandas and for the user there is
literally no different we should be
creating an API where we they find that
you are able to access pandas objects
for for importing and exporting data in
in a certain way implement all our
libraries in a similar way as we are
doing with extension arrays having that
and then the three party developers can
develop them and that you are able to
use them in the same way as you will use
that I think that would make the code
much clearer it would create like
much better structure of code where we
have like several modules that they all
look the same with other developers to
say okay you're welcome to create your
format it doesn't matter we don't know
about all the formants in the world but
you do because you need it so you can
create it and it would be like a really
well supported like or integrated with
with pandas they and a pair would be
consistent no matter if it's a
third-party module or not there won't be
affected says before between a coral
party and for the user it would be as
easy as Conda install your plug-in on an
import plug-in as PL just to make sure
that people in the scientific Python
world is happy having a short alias for
for that and also probably like
delegating some of this work I
personally believe that Google gbq like
the Google bigquery actually is charging
users to for every for the data for the
bandwidth that they have with their API
s-- so it literally means that every
time that someone is calling pandas
don't read gb gbq2 girl is getting money
out of it and we're maintaining this
library you know every time which I
think it sounds a bit wrong to me so I
would personally take this out of the of
the of pandas and having it a third
party module and let Google take care of
that I'm sure they they will be happy to
do that and finally going to the direct
methods that's a bit more the treasure
because it's a bit going a bit far even
in in what I think we should be doing
that is like we saw this before that is
like we can have something like like
over column that interval dot dot
lengths like having the access or cell
ready or having these weird syntax or we
can even go and say you actually I use
intervals alerts away I need to be
calling interval all the time I'm not
calling for numerical operations I'm not
calling them all the time so I can just
like inject directly some methods into
into data frame unserious interesting
fact serious cat at the moment 237
public attributes and methods okay well
it looks like a moat of time let's just
give me one minute
I'm finish that they actually got
different timing here anyway
but yeah it's like full of things in the
first order category four four four the
numerical values but not even one for
intervals I think we should be we should
be injecting that because if you are
using intervals or other structures that
are not known by base basically you're a
second-class citizen you cannot use
direct methods like like that please
forgive us for that and I think I'm
gonna conclude here I just got a couple
of his lights more bad yeah looks like I
got if I've got 30 minutes and I got 25
okay well anyway thank you thank you
you